今じゃあ外れ出場ですあの昔ですねしゃくれプラーネットっていう方々を回したと思う
んですけどもこちらにあります理由トライ8 panda とコアラと
宮キャットが当たりましたレイヤーですごいかわいくてくれても高いんですけども
全員あごが出ています
うんちて気素敵だよほんとってきたら今回なんと
しゃくれるラフェットの第2弾が出たらしいノーヴェござい
あの c 増加がガチャガチャの車くれるブレント売り切れてました売り切るってどう
いうことをこんな店
こんな素晴らしいフィギュアは売り切れますできればそんな素晴らしい一には売り切れ
て当然ですよ地図を塗ってなかったのでバターが通るに入ったタイミングで秋葉原の
ガチャ撮影はたくさんあるお店でそこで回って来ましたあそこに暮らす動物たちは皆
しゃくれている自ら孫
を進化させることで絶滅の危機を乗り越えてきたからだとでもバリバリ
木々も僕防具今もバッグバッグ茶くれるプラネットそれはそう遠くはない未来の地球な
のかもしれない
素晴らしいちょっと者が今の地球儀住んでる動物立つも我々人間もスカイソーラ生きて
いくためにあを出してくれると擦れない
それをこのフィギュアはもう最先端先取り
してもう未来の姿をフィギュア化してしまったというスーパー心理がでございます
売り切れまずはそれはピュッとしたらこの地球にも
すでに昨れている人類がいるかも知れませんぐがー
[音楽]
ん
いやーなんだけど
脳内に直接語りかけてきたと
まあいいだろうマネージャー取れずロックを上げていきますひとつ一つ目は誰が出る
でしょうか
はいでつい最
わーちょっ待って待って待ってでましたーい
僕ワーフ馬場もありネズミですねあにネズミが出ましたが
この子も青子が咲くれていますぱネズミですら動かしてくれてしまいますはい時に右目
ハリネズミでした
この大きさで200円すマジふざけ右端いきましょーがんばってこれも2
言いたいんだけどそうまさかそうちょいちょい
ああああああ
やば一番かぶってはいけないような登録かぶってしまった可愛いねやばいこのサイズに
100円でしょ
ちょっと焦ってきました残り4つ値下げでいきましょう
持ってこれも釣りたいさっきこっちは強化これ小さい予定待って待ってるんじゃないよ
餌は
違うありえるじゃないああああああ
ウサギさんが出ましたしゃくれてます犯人済みで比べてもちょっと大きいですこれ3つ
で600円です
あと3つが大きいから多分落ちる気がするぞ4つ目ですこれでは大きい
重さ的にああ
あっはぁこいつに関しては正面から見てもちょっと不細工だなぁ横から見たらこんな
感じですこの方ちょっと笑ってるんですよ実は本当にカオスてんだ混ぜで前回の卵43
のサイズかがすぐにというねこれ友達だな
すごいな大深くが増えてきたぞ残り二つです開けていきましょう
いやーちょっとこれじゃかぶって干せないいきますはい
婆ってかいは枯れてる分かれてるオーナーもう組み合わせないと作れない奴ですはい
出来ました
これはクジラですねーあああこれは凄いぞ
あっあんでカーッ次でロサン国会ちょっと do do
メンター完成
あっはっは
あっはぼ粗糖過去最大傾斜くれてますねバースターロウですね最後の日てるさくれる版
バローですなーこいつで地元2よろしくそれ
ええええええ
ぶうううう
なんだ今のああ
auto トミックスううううううーん困ったどうよ
アクが炸裂いたら乗り移ってしまったからさああるん
うわぁ
me
いっ